E
ANOPLE OWALLR TH
MOVE ON TO SOCISECURITYAL
INION,
L BE UNABLE AY BTIS, YOU HAVE
ARE NOT INQUOTOCIAL
DOES THIT YOU HAVE
COMMTE
NETIRENTD
E TO YOU.
INTO THIS.
MONEY OUT OF.ENTIRE, LIFE THEY'V
DS TO BELFATILI'M
DEPEN SOY. IA
WN
GRANDMOTHEO 1.
OF INCOME.
.
ENT AGE, IT USED
T IRAT?HAT PEOPLE WOULD SAY,WELS
OBLEM IN THE LAST
FIVEE
I DON'YOCA
THE RETIREMENT AGE WHEN OUR
EXPECTANCY IS COLLAPSING
ITSELF.N A HUGE PRLEND OF
MES BENEFITS.
IN THIS HIGHNFENVIRONMENT, GROCO
UT IT'OT ENOUGH TO COVER THE AT
ST INCREASED.
. RTULCO, AND THEY MUS
TO GET INFLATI
, ENEROSN, THE
WILL BE THIN
RO>> PIFICATION,SECONDTEEN
ARE NOT SAYING THAT YOU ARECOMME
RETIREMEFG>> I WNEVER RAISE
DEINK THBAD.
IT.
AR FOLKS.
LI EXPECTAY T EVEN RNGBE.
>> THANK YOU GERNOR.
GOVERNOR HALEY?
E
TO 70 YEARTH.E
GO TO SAM,ND
YOU WILL SEE IT.
TEYOU, BECAUSE HE'S RUNNINRPRESH
YOU CAN'T TRUST HIM.
CI SECURITY WILL GO
MEDIRE
HE TKS TAK BUT RIGHT NOW, IN
A,
SPOT.
S THE HIT F
LIVING OF ANY STATE IN TTRSENIOE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT.
MENTED ANDLI.COM.
WHAT I WILL TELL W TO
DO IS WES
SANFOR THOSE MICRON, SAYING THE
TOUCH SOCIAL SECURITY,
THAT MEANS THAT THEY WILL LEAVE
R 4 TO 8 YEARS, AND LEAVE
BANKRT?NO.
THE RETIREMENT AGE
TO RLE,
D OF COST OF LIVING
BASED WE LIMIT BENEFITS ON THE G
SURE TY >>FITSYOU CE
TS --
UNR ADUT
GNGST OF LING ADJUSTMENTS
WHILE UR TAX DOLLARS ARE
ABOUTTI AMERICAN
WE HAVE TO PUT>> GOVERNOR HALEYM
SPEA SHE ALSO SAID, RECENTAT THI
CRITICIZED THAT.
WAS EID, SHE NEVER COURSE, YOU .
SURE EE
INTERVIEW WHERE SH T,
NG IMAGE,
LOW.
WE CAN PLAY THIS SONG AND DANCE,
E'CORD, HAS
STEMENTS, AND I THINK PAF
HER CANDIDACY IS THAT  SCRUTIN E
OBLEM WITH B
PODIATRISH ON
THE FOOTEVYING THINGS THAT, DONS
FROME.
THANK YOU, GORNDESANTIS.
VEEALEY, YOU WANT TO
OUHAT THATU'VE NOT S
>> HE HA ANSWER, HE SAID
DIFFERENT TIMES.
CVERY NAME AND
WANTS, HESTHEAS MUCH AS HE
FACT THAAUSE
WHAT WILL TELL YOU YES, SE
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE --
WHEN I SAID THE RETIREMENT AGETO
LYING, BECAUSE I'S
I
O K
TWENTIES.
WE HAVE TO GO AND LOWHAT
IT.F
BUNT TO MAKE SURE
THE WAAT IS EXACTLY
THEN WE
ANCAN
FOCUSING.
HE TO GO BAO PRE-COVIDD
SP DOES ET
I DID THAT AVERY AGENC
CLEAN THOSE AGENCIESN FOCU
F WASTTANT GCL ARE NT
VOTE THELSHE
.
IN 15 SECONDS,RS IN
N ON HAVING
TO
REASEDYES.
REFLECT MOREEXPECTANCY SHOULD B.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DISAGRIS
IS AENT.OCIAL SERI
BUT IT'S NOT AN ENTITLEMENT,
YOU' IT.
AM, YOU
E SURPLUSES.ING I SOCIAL SECURI
WHHOSESURPSENT THE
SURPLUSES.
>> YES, WHEN THEY RAISE THE
>>LEM WITH
THAT.
NUWE NEEPRESENT TO GANNUAKG KILM
LIKE NANCYLD
N A LUCRATIVE HEDGE